so welcome back everybody and without
further ado I'm going to ask professor
Spivak to introduce our plenary speaker
for the evening sarvasah please join me
in extending a warm vote of thanks for
professor feyza Spivak thank you for
asking me janaki it is it truly is a
great honor to be asked to introduce our
insane I've long admired her I'm not
going to I think if you allow me Janicki
I'm not going to go for 15-20 minutes
because we are very late I say most of
this introduction was a recounting of
the many many things she's done I'll
summarize so we can we can hear her so I
can hear her but I do want to respond
very briefly if you will allow me both
to the spectacular panel we had before
guitars point that secularism is about
freedom of religion this is an important
point it seems to me and I you know I'm
a literary person and so most social
scientists are very impatient with us
because we seem to draw conclusions
social conclusions from the study of one
fictive text this is a disciplinary
problem we have I am going to give you
just one example of two things one
example each but this is not a case for
proving evidentiary truths it's actually
two counter-examples the freedom of
religion how it operates even outside of
necessarily secular law before I do that
I should express my own convictions I
think that in the current context we
have no alternative to a
that can be loosely described as secular
the separation of church and state it is
in a double bind with the fact that the
intuition of the transcendental is what
allows us both to mourn and to judge I'm
against capital punishment but certainly
to execute and this is the problem that
there without this the so-called human
cannot distinguish itself as human this
is the problem this is it's not religion
in certain kinds of political contexts
we can see that the Diaspora bees are
strongly responding to the monolith
ization of Islam and the people located
people are strongly responding to the
internal problems problems internal to
located Islam it's clear as crystal I
don't think there is any kind of problem
there unless you want to claim the other
situation and I must honestly say that I
will continue to think because of what
what Afiya said that the political
political appropriateness of the located
struggles it really is very very
different from the whatever problems you
have from a chosen civil society
elsewhere but one can respect both
struggles and our our our situation is
that while we insist in the current
context it's got nothing to do with
history tradition nothing in the current
context we must insist on secular laws
at the same time we must acknowledge and
here is a formula coming from a
humanities teacher uncor Civ
rearrangement of desire we must at the
same time notice that it is only in
certain contexts that the religious
impulse is so politicized that the only
way it can operate is in a destructive
way and in that context what to do I've
written at great length on this but of
course I'm only an academic person I
have no influence on policymakers but
one hopes one writes for the
philosophers of the future perhaps
someone will pick it up someday but at
any rate my counter-examples before I go
now both of these will involve stories
that suggests that I'm an activist I am
a bit of an activist but very minor okay
very very minor I have seen full-time
activists so don't get me wrong I'm not
trying to prove anything here they come
out of that context the first one is
when I used to work at night schools in
a place called sheet guns north of Japan
our guns you know that Rajshahi area and
the the women there they were very very
poor they really had no access to fish
and meat etc okay except for Corbin
image which was beef and they would eat
it I would eat and talk about religious
freedom you see this is why one can
rearrange desires as one goes up they
would say to me sister
they protected my religion there was a
sister we are eating this karana beef
it's okay why are you eating this they
were protecting my religion now that
grassroots respecting of the freedom of
religion they were not I mean of course
it came from remember this a counter
example this is not going to lead to
anything evidentiary so to an extent we
can build on this in double bind with
the absolute need for secular laws
that's one another is when a barefoot
teacher barefoot teacher and I were on a
trawler 1991 1991 cyclone where EU had
as it was then it had given a lot of age
okay rice and lentils and we are going
just the two of us and the two both be
two or three board people and as we are
going it's fantastic that's huge we have
been goal all the little electricity has
been kind of knocked off I mean it's
really emits it gives you a kind of aha
sensation right so we're moving but at a
certain point the boatman say assisters
the tide is so high we are not going to
be able to dock the trawler so we are
going to have to just wait until dawn so
I say to the
barefoot teacher shut it's all right you
go to sleep I'm sitting in front and she
says I don't think I'm gonna sleep
either
now the boatman brought came up and
started cooking and they established the
absolute limits of our freedom
beautifully by doing what talking
politics once you start talking politics
you know that there's not gonna be any
gender trouble here and remember these
were complete as if I may use the word
subaltern folks right and so they say
and I there are many people here who
understand Bengali so I'll say it in
Bengali first they say a BA am la bouche
a relief Allah a DC that's how they
began that we have 1991 remember we have
thrown away sister we have thrown away
the relief given to us by Bush that's
where I'm not going to I'm not gonna
talk about a whole long thing
I just wanna maybe another story the
Dhaka Airport mmm Dhaka Airport all all
movement closed I'm sitting there people
are kind of you know camping on the
floor why because the as they the
mullahs Bashar Muslim echo-hawk let oh
please all the international Muslims
come together and so the airport is
closed so a guy had come to gas me and
says he says let's walk it's only twenty
three months like this young problem so
we're walking okay and then at a certain
point the rickshaw wallahs coming out
they said you know the Tigers have gone
into pray buggy Righetti baccarat get a
not worth it now I think for a little
while we could take you in in our
rickshaws so again local local movement
against so-called fundamentalist Islam
in Bangladesh so you can collect many
counter examples of the sort and you can
say that there is scope for
and uncurse is rearrangement of desire
so that the will to a separation of
church and state without denying the
need for the intuition of the
transcendental can happen but if such a
day is to come then we must also
emphasize and and Saracen does so and
this is part of my introduction we must
emphasize how we train how we teach of
course but also how we train I do not
think I mean I like the phrase secular
Islam you know why because all through
my use we thought that the Jewish
atheists were the best example of the
European documents leader - van Hagen
Hannah Arendt and so forth the best
things are so if they can be Jewish
atheists
there can be secular Muslims II know
it's a nice club to belong to but that's
not the problem
the real problem is that I think in this
conjuncture in located areas everywhere
including this place we cannot deny the
importance of secular laws even as we
recognize that our obligation each one
of us is to assist in the uncurse if
rearrangement of desires so that the
intuition of the transcendental is
protected without what happens to
religion in a political situation it is
mobilized into belief but it's open much
more open into the imagination when in
fact it's not it doesn't have its back
against the wall and when it combines
with gender politics because the state
is not getting recognition
internationally it becomes a lethal
combination and there I believe the
located areas and the diasporic areas
begin to come together now that's all
I'm going to say for myself in response
to the previous panel and I want to
start in the name of justice I'm used up
I've used up already ten minutes okay so
I want to speak a start in the name of
justice because
Sahra at a certain point brought up that
issue why are we not talking about
justice we say social justice we say
gender justice but justice by itself and
you know perhaps the the scholars since
I don't read Arabic the used to be able
to speak my gravy Arabic at a certain
point but I certainly don't read it but
I don't want to go on Allah girl but it
does seem to me well it does seem to me
that the slim text like falooda a man's
text where he suggests from within a
historical separation of justice from
the law within the tradition of Islam
because it's a critique that's coming
from within before all of this had
become so aggravated I certain lots of
Arabic documentation which I can't
follow I have taken a certain degree of
of I've taken notice of that and if I
were if ever to work on it I would look
at that historical separation just as
our as we look at the historical
destruction of the welfare state
starting from Reagan's deregulation and
the collapsing of the commercial and the
investment banks together so what the I
would say also having used up ten
minutes that the subaltern does not
generalize today it does not generalize
you cannot generalize different examples
of the subaltern today in fact what the
men and women are fighting in wall
street is the fact that capital social
productivity which is what all of the
corporate funding and general
international civil society I hope Sofia
is here the fear is here because that's
what they're she and I are one they
never acknowledge that the social
productivity of capital which Marx also
believed in which is where the Communist
League called him a capitalist the
social productivity of capital requires
sub authorization not proletarianization
anymore because that's just a bit of it
because the factory floor has been
pulverized and
the current motor production but in
supportin ization in the sense of
dismantling of the welfare state ram
she's wonderful definition in his
historiography of the supports and
classes is the subaltern classes are
those that do not
in fact access or achieve the state and
it's a Spivak in english but this is not
quite drum she's italian but nonetheless
that's what it is
he could not have imagined that in fact
the that structure of the state could be
dismantled and these young men and women
the from the first day critique of
political economy that is to say Wall
Street and Washington together and the
inability to live as they are being
withdrawn from the welfare structures of
the state that's called sub organization
so let me tell you that some of the
subaltern in Bangladesh we assume you're
also dealing since you are a founding
member right of I know Sally's but you
were on the executive committee for
three years I know Sandra which is a
fantastic fantastic institution the
subaltern in Bangladesh or the subaltern
in West Bengal or the subaltern in the
rest of India and Kerala they do not
resemble each other and the subaltern is
not a primitive as I say our brothers
and sisters in wall street are fighting
against critique of political economy on
the model of a general strike we need a
Rosa Luxemburg on the model of a general
strike fighting against some
organization so that said let me let me
take the 55 minutes to praise you and
then we will hear I my own connections
with feminism in Bangladesh has we have
been long-standing indeed although this
is not the moment for autobiographical
reflections
both my parents were involved in life
transforming ways in the matter of
women's rights in what is today
Bangladesh it is also from this point of
view that it is a special honor for me
to present a woman with a lifelong
commitment
to the welfare of women Sara Hussein it
is customary on such occasions to
mention first the education and honors
of the guests and I will do so cutting
myself off and reading the final
paragraph when I hit the hit my time
limit I will do so reserving for myself
the special pleasure in tabulating her
involvement not only in women's welfare
but general social justice and she asked
about justice remember what no I will
ad-lib a little more what is it to ask
the question of justice it is just that
there be law but law is not justice it
is to emphasize the fact that women even
in the most supportin areas are human
and can indeed wish for justice as such
which is not just winning legal battles
and for someone who's a barrister to be
able to say that is for me an incredible
blessing also when in fact one thinks
about justice in this way one knows that
what one is talking about will travel
far this is why I mean I want to cite
here WB Dubois who wrote right after the
emancipation of the slaves not he was
not alive then he's writing in his book
black reconstruction
he says the Negro needs food clothing
and shelter but at once also to
communicate with the Stars
that is the question of justice these
people are human they are not just there
for conflict resolution and
reconciliation what the hell would be
reconciled with so to an extent justice
is a much harder word and I was so happy
to hear it from that just another word I
have said so now her her her her
education and honors Sarah Hussein
received an MA in jurisprudence with
honors at Wadham College Oxford in 1988
called to the bar at the Middle Temple
in 89 admitted to the Bangladesh Bar in
1993 admitted to the High Court Division
of the Supreme Court of organization 92
2008 enrolled in the Appellate Division
of the Supreme Court of Bangladesh many
honors
among them I will mention Asia Society
Asia 21,000 and seven names young global
leader by the World Economic Forum 2008
I'm being ironic here it's okay it's
possible for us to get a get get honors
from associations that well I'm not
gonna turn my back on those kinds of
honors I'll say listen we're gonna
transform people the it's why should we
hide tokenization is something that we
should admit to and then turn it around
so that's why I mentioned it received
the Ananya top 10 women's award 93-94
human rights lawyer award from human
rights first in New York elected as a
member of the International Commission
of Jurists in 2010 vice president of the
Law Review of the law students research
center in taa member of I know savage
general haka that many in this room will
be well-acquainted with serving on the
executive committee from 2003 to 2005
trustee of the well-known international
civil society organization war on want
based in London member of the Advisory
Committee of women's International
Coalition for gender justice based in
The Hague since 2008 member of the Human
Rights Committee of the International
Law Association and I could go on
interstices of this busy activist life
on the highest level she has made time
to go edit handbook on legal remedies
for forced marriage an important volume
on human rights in Bangladesh with Ian
Byrne she has written the entry on
Bangladesh in a volume on social rights
jurisprudence published in 2008 the
clean Welshman co-edited an important
book honor crimes paradigms and violence
against women simultaneously appearing
from zee press in london zubaan press in
New Delhi and spins Express in Australia
same year she co-edited with Deena
Siddiqui a book on human rights in
Bangladesh published many articles I'm
not going to say anything
skipping being a consultant for the one
more minute for the United Nations
Development Programme and so on ok she's
beginning to feel a little embarrassed
by all of this
leave me but independent expert on
cultural rights partners for law in
development in India this is for me very
very important and what I really feel is
the important thing is this training on
you know she trains governments she
trains lawyers and she trains women at
the bottom which i think is a fantastic
thing I could go on about seed or and
her actions for seed or the United
States being you know elimination of all
forms of discrimination against women
the convention the United States being
one of only six countries including Iran
Sudan Somalia Palau and Tonga that have
not yet ratified seed or and so I thank
you for your work with seed or and what
I have really this is now when she talks
about her litigation support
interventions requirement of proof of
force and rapist gender discriminatory
marital rapist gender discrimination and
so on this is the cutting edge of
women's subjectivity subjectivity theory
the woman who is going to speak for us
today has combined such theorization
with practice at the highest possible
level what I have said so far and I'm
right on twenty minutes so far is my own
sense of her work in her resume we read
that her main practice areas are
constitutional human rights and public
interest law and family law and that her
recent cases have included challenges to
government inaction regarding
extrajudicial penalties in traditional
dispute resolution processes the
practice of forced veiling forced
marriage and sexual harassment at this
point I want to tell a million stories
no ladies and gentlemen if anybody can
tell us about Democratic contents
contestation on behalf of women across
social strata in Bangladesh in South
Asia and internationally it is are
obscene it is completely appropriate
that she should say the last word for us
on secularism and feminism please join
me in welcoming sir I was saying most
warmly
okay that was was massively over the top
and I hope everyone is charmed as I was
by it I would like to thank I through
the enormous Lior not really because I
was actually rather terrified when I
heard that she was going to be
introducing me and she's definitely
taken the terror away but I also want to
thank my friend Dina Siddiqui very much
indeed for having involved me in this
process and forced me to write things
down again which I don't like to do very
often unless they're short petitions for
courts I feel also quite intimidated in
speaking in the presence of someone else
who's in this room matters as a son who
is someone I think in South Asia at
least for anyone involved in the legal
profession he is a legend and the
movement he led was an inspiration for
all of us in South Asia in Bangladesh we
haven't been able to do anything like
what you were able to do in Pakistan I
think we're as far away from it as
possible at this point but in many other
areas in Bangladesh we have done much
and I think we can talk about that and
share that with colleagues from Pakistan
colleagues working on Pakistan but the
way I thought I would speak and and
being in a room of academics I think I
should say quite clearly at the
beginning I'm really not an academic of
any kind and I've been a practitioner
stroke activist what-have-you
for the last 20 years so what I want to
speak about what I titled my talk very
much to do with security
it probably could do and I probably
could bring it into it but I don't think
I've thought it through very well but it
does have a lot to do with democratic
conversations at different levels and
what I titled my talk was strokes of a
pendulum Bangladesh 40 years on in
experiences of seeking justice um
I guess a little caveat I'd like to
start with which was sort of occasioned
by a tea break conversation at the i3
day this morning was exactly this notion
of justice and how do we understand
justice and language is very pertinent
in Bengali at least there are two words
that you play with Nagata justice Beach
are also justice but more giving a sense
of some kind of accountability or legal
process and I think you know with the
tensions between those those two notions
of fuller concept concept of justice
which may or may not involve legal
processes and remedies and the process
of beecher that tension is something I
also want to talk through but before I
begin I want to start with quoting a few
words from a singer called Hyder Hussein
named can you burn me with this video
it's probably just a button right
Thanks
so this was hire a Zen let me just cook
translate for those of you who didn't
follow the Bangla and he starts by
saying what do we what were we to see
what should we have seen and what do we
see before us what were we to hear and
what do I hear what do we hear what were
we to have felt in what do we feel what
were we to have said and what do we say
and he says thirty years on I will have
to say 40 years on freedom is still
evading me and in the next stanza the
pictures of what you saw he talks about
these are annual cultural functions by
boys Shakti but the new year and he
talks about intellectual seminars and
about the ceremonial and ritual of
celebrating of Independence High the
reason I guess I suspect is probably the
same generation is us and his song and
it continues really to give voice not
only to the hope but the dashed hopes I
think in the sense of disillusionment
and disenchantment with a very hard won
democratic process which has been
experienced by many of us who were part
of the poster child generation as I
would call it in Bangladesh for many of
them or rather for many of us all over
40-somethings now we were too young to
have directly experienced or
participated in the foundational moment
of Bangladesh's independence so the nine
year long movement against general
irshad which culminated in the
accelerated protests of 1990 and led
eventually to his fall in 6 December was
the context in which we underwent our
political or activist baptisms of fire
and that period also marked the
beginning of Bangladesh a central
transition I think that was the central
transition from 15 years of autocracy
and military rule back to elected
government that time brought for as many
hopes for an end to impunity to a
process of initiating accountability for
past violations and securing a promise
of democracy
see full of democracy not just elected
government but the possibilities of
greater participation and of the
articulation of hitherto unheard unheard
voices in the future
but two decades on from that now in 2011
like I the reason I think for many of us
our hopes are considerably dimmed our
aspirations much more limited and our
sense of the myriad possibilities for
change tempered with our experience of
reality of course and this point I think
we'll have more resonance for
Bangladeshi colleagues in the room hi
there resign himself now evokes rather
more complicated responses and they are
questioning actually of his critique
given his willingness indeed massive
enthusiasm to engage in explicit songs
appraised to the military during the
last prolonged chaotic administration
which operated during the states of
emergency today with the hindsight of
four decades we can discuss the
questions which are the focus of this
conference in the context of the several
transitions through which we lived in
Bangladesh first again the moment of
independence second the transition into
a period of autocracy and militarism
commencing in 75 and some might say more
controversially perhaps that it may have
commenced in 74 with the establishment
of one-party rule that's a difficult
thing to say these days but I might just
risk saying it
third the return to elected government
in 1990 as I mentioned and then what we
saw after that the partisan polarization
and fissures within society and the
brinksmanship of the two leading
political parties which ultimately led
to the moment on the edge of the
precipice in 2006 which segwayed into
the caretaker regime of 2007 and 8 and
finally led to where we are now the
restoration of elected government from
late 2008 onwards so now on the cusp of
that 40th anniversary of the first major
moment of transition into independence
and nationhood we're going to see start
there already already started to a
degree celebrations in commemoration of
that moment of departure from Pakistan
and the charting of a new course for new
people and a new nation given the
opening of this conference and I think
what we heard in the first sessions as
well as the discussions of atrocities
and Jen
side of 1977 and 71 but in the absence
of the naming of certain names and the
absence of the identification of the
role of religious extremism and
militarism and I should mention I think
the extremism not just of non-state
actors of political parties but also of
the state and the combination and
collusion of them I would like to make
it clear that I don't think we can
proceed without more clarity and without
naming names and without an
identification of political and social
locations this is important because for
many years under military rule and later
even under elected government when we
had governments with extremist religious
parties in power in coalition
governments it was never possible to
actually name who was responsible for
the genocide who was responsible for the
atrocities in 71 you couldn't you always
talked about the enemy forces but you
could never say the enemy forces were
actually the Pakistan army led by
Pakistan generals and with the
participation of Pakistan politicians
and unfortunately the silence of much of
Pakistani society also and you couldn't
talk also about who the local
collaborators were whether Bengalis non
Bengalis in those Muslims Christians
whoever and you couldn't talk about the
nature of the violence that was
perpetrated that it was violence
perpetrated on Bengalis and non Bengalis
in those Muslims Christians animus
persons of no faith or living in the
territories that now comprise Bangladesh
and today we have by the reason I want
to mention all this at the beginning is
because I think at this point forty
years on while we in Bangladesh are
secure within our own territories and as
I said celebrating and commemorating we
face a situation where globally there
are many efforts to dismiss and negate
these realities at many levels at
certain within academic discourse maybe
in the form of the kinds of publications
you've seen like Shore meal abortions
recent book for example or indeed this
morning and I don't want to be
discourteous to one of our those who
have supported this conference but I was
struck and I have to
see I'm somewhat distressed by the
comments made by our opening speaker the
ambassador who spoke about his his
discussion with Bangladesh as prime
minister and referred to her oblique
they Bangladeshis being quote worked up
about things I think he's right we are
worked up about things and probably were
worked up about things for very good
cause precisely because of these ellipse
illusions and ellipses in the
discussions at a global level and the
inability it seems to confront the past
and how that contours the present so
what I want to try and do is talk
through three three issues and if you
like three different kinds of encounters
with processes or structures for seeking
justice I start I guess given that we
have talked about 71 with the issue of
facing and naming the past and with the
efforts to end impunity and seek justice
for war crimes and crimes against
humanity after that I want to talk about
something drier and I hope you won't
fall asleep but I want to talk about
what actually is for me the most
important issue and perhaps for us and
also the issue of Independence of the
judiciary and about the institutional
process that we have for trying to
deliver in effect justice and thirdly I
want and I want to talk particularly
about the armed pressures which then
which the judiciary is faced and the
subordination the judiciary has itself
embraced rather too heartily I would say
and thirdly I want to talk about the
role of that that that is involved in
terms of reducing Democratic space and
then thirdly I want to talk about how
people's organizations and citizens
groups have worked to fight and maneuver
for some kind of representation of their
own interests within the narrow spaces
that are available to us within the
processes justice so to begin at the
beginning
with the issue of 1971 and the
unresolved question of crimes against
humanity
the problem of impunity which of course
marks 71 as well as deeply embedded in
Bangladesh is just a system in the
darkest times it was grafted onto the
Constitution by military rulers through
indemnity laws and it continues still to
permeate and obstruct efforts at seeking
accountability the horrors of massacres
political killings and violent conflicts
have smeared our landscape over 40 years
many of these are known to you of course
the assassination of our first president
Sheikh Mujibur Rahman is most of his
family
subsequent killings of our prime
minister and other leading politicians
and jails the secret trial and hanging
of colonel tyre and the general Xia's
regime killings within the military
throughout the 70s and of course massive
brutal killings of civilians throughout
the entire period which are not so much
recorded in the grand political
histories all of those as I said the
blood of all those people is smeared our
landscape for 40 years but I won't talk
about all this here I'll try and focus
on the issue of war crimes and the
effort that is now being made finally
with the establishment of the
international crimes tribunal based upon
a statute which was first enacted in
1973 in the immediate aftermath of the
War of Independence
it was a statute which was then
developed on the basis of input from
international lawyers and base if you
remember in 1973 very much on the
notions and understanding of
international criminal law at the time
based really on an understanding of
justice for war crimes premise upon
really the Nuremberg tribunals and those
principles long this was long before the
Hague tribunals long before Bosnia long
before Cambodia no notion of those kinds
of principles that had been developed
there were available to us the purpose
so we have this light anomaly in that we
have a piece of legislation from 1973
being revived in 2010 and created and
enabling the creation of a tribunal to
try crimes of 40 years ago the purpose
of this Tribunal is limited it's to try
those bang
she's who were involved in committing
international crimes including crimes
against humanity and genocide currently
seven men all of them who are being
leaders of opposition parties - from the
main opposition party the Bangladesh
Nationals party in five from the
jamaat-e-islami are in detention and one
of them was last week indicted on 20
counts involving crimes against humanity
and genocide in some times it seems that
it's unknown to recent international
observers of this Bangladeshi trial
process that the development of the
establishment of the courts has come in
response not simply to a flick of a wand
by a government which is hell-bent on
destroying its opposition I won't say
that they don't have that as a
motivation I'll come back to that but it
hasn't come only because of that and it
couldn't have come only because of that
this development has come in response to
decades of unrelenting struggle and
demands from civil society including
freedom fighters survivors groups and
rights organization and it also came in
the wake of an election in which the
pledge to hold such a trial appears to
have contributed significantly to its
outcomes and particularly in terms of
the influence it appears to have played
on young people as a factor for bringing
into power the current ruling coalition
I haven't fortune no time to go into the
early history of the efforts to seek
justice and the immediate post-war
period in any way I hope some of this is
known to you but I think it's important
to put on record why this effort in
Bangladesh is critical there hasn't been
an international process in 40 years
there hasn't been a process in Pakistan
to bring anyone to justice in 40 years
and although of course there have been
these extremely important
efforts at apologies and there have been
critical individual and institutional
solidarity is being oppressed expressed
to God across several societies across
both countries the government of
Pakistan in the States has remained
obdurate when refusing to acknowledge
the events or their responsibility for
them as mentioned this morning Pakistan
sole effort to date though it's never
been officially acted upon was the
Commission of Inquiry presided over by
retired justice
hammoudi Ramon formed in December 1971
the report of that Inquiry Commission of
course challenged Bangladeshis claims
regarding the numbers of dead the
numbers of war affected but it did admit
widespread killings of civilians
including intellectuals Bengali officers
and soldiers and indiscriminate killing
of Hindus it also admitted the use of
rape and sexual violence for revenge
retaliation and torture that of course
that report wasn't made public until
very very many years later with in
Bangladesh in the immediate aftermath of
the war there were high expectations
that those responsible for the
atrocities would be prosecuted although
the top ranking leaders of the Pakistan
Army were not within the jurisdiction of
the bond or bond with each and many of
the leaders of the so-called auxiliary
forces it also fled there were some
ninety two thousand Pakistani prisoners
of war held in India along with
civilians however as a consequence of a
number of agreements as a gesture of
goodwill so characterize India began the
repatriation of the 92,000 periods POWs
and civilians to Pakistan and ultimately
195 Pakistani POWs who allegedly
implicated directly in the atrocities
were left but then they too were allowed
to be repatriated and Bangladesh
permitted the return to Pakistan of
Pakistani nationals alleged to have
committed atrocities that is certainly
correct but Bangladesh never stated
neither
importantly did Pakistan that the
responsibility of any state to try such
persons for their crimes had been denied
or erased
indeed Pakistan itself early argued
before the International Court of
Justice that it had had exclusive
jurisdiction to try such persons under
article 6 of the Genocide Convention and
I think it was therefore clear that
repatriation of these 195 POWs was only
understanding however flawed or naive
that Pakistan would hold true to its
commitment to hold such trials but as we
know that didn't happen in the meantime
in Bangladesh the founding statute was
enacted in 1973
there were also separate legislation
brought about to try so-called
collaborators but it should be noted
that many of the most senior
collaborators and those against whom
there were very serious allegations of
involvement in abductions and massacres
had left bound with it immediately after
the war many to Pakistan some to Saudi
Arabia and many interestingly to the
United Kingdom and also in the u.s. were
some of them remain today I think this
is maybe a point for just a quick
parenthesis that when we had a
discussion this morning about the issue
of the assassination of the
quote-unquote assassination of our
Lackey the speaker had mentioned the
point there are no charges against
Turkey there are no charges in any
jurisdiction against persons who are
accused of serious allegations of war
crimes in Bangladesh other than in
Bangladesh but that doesn't mean those
allegations don't exist on record that
doesn't mean because a state hasn't
brought charges that there are not
testimonies and affidavits and
statements by survivors about what had
happened there are those regarding
Bangladeshi war criminals but the issue
is there are no processes to bring them
to justice
the issue is that human rights works in
a complex fashion where persons accused
of as I said massacres and abductions
are now able to claim human rights
protections by virtue of being citizens
of the United Kingdom and entitled to
guarantees under the European Convention
including protections against
extradition to any country which
perpetrates the death penalty or carries
out torture but we in Bangladesh have no
protection against that or against them
or any means of seeking redress a visa
some of the unhappy contradictions and
difficulties which we face when we do
believe in enforcing human rights now
the silence of the issue of justice for
trustees was ruptured it was very
difficult to speak about these issues
for many many years but it was ruptured
in moments and one of them one of the
most important moments perhaps was nynuk
alluded to this morning was the holding
of the so called gonadal of the people's
tribunal in 1992 this was led by John
our Imam known as Chui John on your
mother
Marta who had lost her son in in the
liberation war and the people's tribunal
served to coalesce long silence demands
of justice for the crimes committed in
1971 the event that was held in dark at
that time garnered massive public
support and in retrospect it was a clear
landmark in the movement for justice
relating to 1971 but involvement in the
movement I want to mention this because
I think you need to understand what the
cost has been of making these demands of
justice
for justice because environment for
those who were part of the gonadal earth
and participated in its processes met
with serious retaliatory measures from
the government of the day it initiated
criminal cases for sedition against key
persons including well-known freedom
fighters and the bereaved families of
intellectuals killed in the war so those
seeking to break the pattern of impunity
in to demand justice instead found
themselves caught up in the coils of the
criminal justice system themselves
having to surrender before the High
Court at a very unfortunately routine
pattern of abusive process seek bail and
then fight to prove the innocence of
these vexatious and abusive claims this
experience took place against a backdrop
of growing international awareness on
issues of impunity and accountability
and the establishment by the end of new
justice mechanisms such as the
International tribunals in the hague and
if this raised in turn bub new public
debates in Bangladesh about the need and
what seemed began to seem the glimmer of
a real possibility about developing a
comprehensive justice agenda to address
international crimes so cutting the
story short of the no the bumpy ride
that continued after that finally in
2008 given the continuing and activism
around the issues of accountability for
war crimes these really gathered
momentum ironically under the emergency
the state of emergency when all
traditional or all ordinary politics was
banned and as a consequence cross one of
the few pitches on which one could speak
out on with political actors was around
the issue war crimes and give the
discourse coalesced around the need now
much more refined amount to establish a
Tribune and to began begin the process
of trials the sum of again the leading
voices in this were cross party
platforms a former freedom fighters
sector commanders I'm civil society
organizations that had campaigned for 40
years and again the children of the
martyrs
now where do we stand now what has
happened between 2008 to 2011 in 2010
the Bangladesh government after a year
or so of delay finally appointed judges
established the tribunal named
prosecutors and investigators however it
has not yet begun any process of public
information or discussion regarding the
nature of the proposed proceedings and
despite welcome reiteration that
international standards and best
practices in the area of international
justice will be applied it is really
quite unclear and opaque as to how this
will occur and whether the trunk the the
tribunal staff will be given the
necessary resources and opportunities to
acquire the necessary expertise and
understanding of the more complicated
international legal procedures that have
developed since nineteen years 73 to
address these issues amongst the public
while there's a large groundswell of
opinion in favour of accountability
there's also I think less clarity on how
to deal with the past what should be
done how it should be done whether and
what kind of social repair is necessary
with any kind of healing is possible
whether the tribunal is a tall and
adequate mechanism for doing that and
above all I think the questions which
are really unasked as well as unanswered
about what works and what doesn't work
and ensuring justice in the broader
sense and sustainable peace well many
have been vocal in calling for trials
and now that we have the tribunal in
calling for expeditious process many
also remain deeply concerned about how
the tribunal will function in practice
and most critically about whether
adequate and tiny measures are being
taken to enable to take enabler to take
on the enormous task that lies ahead and
related to this I think we have to ask
what will happen following this trial
how are we in Bangladesh move forward as
a society how will anyone who gives
witness who gives evidence before this
trial returned to their everyday lives
I think these in these issues including
how to address the complexity of the
violence of 1971 and its diversity are
again questions that are unfortunately
remaining unasked in the
to try and get some kind of resolution
so while the conduct affair trials by
the ICT is an enormous challenge this
moment in history also presents a window
of opportunity to engage in some kind of
social repair I think we need to think
about how we don't squander this
opportunity how do we ensure that this
process means if not international gold
standards at least minimum domestic
standards are to process how do we
ensure justice for everybody not just
the accused but the victims and how will
the tribunal overcome the major hurdles
faced by survivors in our routine
everyday criminal justice system the
problems of exertion of political
influence of the lack of safety and
security of endemic corruption and abuse
of process will the tribunal look at the
experiences of other institutions and
learn its lessons I think these
questions and more remain to be answered
in the month said as bandwidth issues
there is some hope and I think we do
look forward that it may still may just
possibly enable us to construct a
narrative that seeks to understand what
forces in society allowed such
atrocities to happen and it also might
allow survivors of such violence to
claim redress recognition and respect
for these reasons I support the critical
importance of undertaking and pursuing
that the the exercise and accountability
for the crimes committed during the
Bangladesh war of liberation I believe
firmly that atrocities occurred that
they occurred upon a particular majority
by a particular group I don't think
there was an equality of arms I don't
think there was an equality of violence
and I think we have to be clear about
that
I do think all forms of violence should
be addressed and the tribunal is not
currently doing that but you have to be
realistic and we have to be honest about
what happened and not try to occlude
that but at the same time I think we
have to see and this is harder to say
very hard to see today in Bangladesh
without being labeled as somehow a
supporter of war criminals it is
essential that we see a credible and
legitimate process the tribunal would be
much more effective if it were to engage
with the lessons learned by the world if
it were not to turn in on itself if it
were to learn of the developments in
zero
prudence without feeling insecure
without feeling nervous about its own
potentials to learn and to integrate
that and most importantly moving on we
need to consider how using the past to
deny the present of wrongdoing an abuse
of power and denial of due process is
not a process in which way mired and we
need to be aware of how the process of
democracy and democratic rights
themselves are in a sense being
contested through the process of the
trials now secondly and this is the dry
of it I guess I want to talk about the
kind of contest stations over democratic
structures and the politicization of the
judicial and the discussion around the
but it's possible politicization of the
ICT in the way in which it may be used
to persecute and harass political
opponents that being seen is one other
perspective on it also really shines a
light on on the processes within the
routine processes rather within the
judiciary and at the structural limits
to seeking justice within the legal
system I want to just look very briefly
at some of the struggles around
Independence of the judiciary and the
executives repeated efforts to dominate
the judiciary in practice and back the
courts and ensure its total control over
the possibility of setting standards and
seeking remedies in the almost four
decades since we've been an independent
nation through the periods of continuing
transition I spoke about the Supreme
Court has been repeatedly the focus of
public attention providing a forum not
only for redress of rights against a
repressive state but also carving out
with greater or lesser caution at
different times parameters for
determining relations between the state
and political parties and more recently
in the last 20 years the duties and
obligations of the state the people of
at large and of course carving out its
own notions very controversially
increasingly of the public interest the
courts approach is oscillated between
permitting full-frontal challenges
followed by correctives to executive
excess in the face of flavor on the
arbitrary action and clear
constitutional breach
but this at this press approach is also
marked efforts made safeguard the courts
own autonomy and expend independence
experiences of executive control and
interference in the Pakistan period and
of course prior to that in the colonial
period clearly informed the framing of
express provisions in the post
independence Constitution of 1972 which
mandated independence judiciary and a
separation from the executive at all
levels the lower judiciary and the
Supreme Court however amendments were
made to the original Constitution
provisions under autocratic rule under
unfortunately Sheikh Mujibur Rahman in
1974 and then under military rule under
General Zia inertia through 1975 onwards
and that meant there was a failure to
overhaul the inherited institutional
structure and we saw the continued
intervention of deeply embedded vested
interests which were further exacerbated
by overt politicization of the court and
new constitutional arrangements which
enabled involvement of the senior-most
members of the judiciary the executive
resulting at various points for example
with Chief Justice is an unhappy I think
history we probably share with Pakistan
of chief justices serving as chief
marshal or administrators for example
and more laterally in their new guises
as caretaker Chiefs as well and that
whole process has certainly diminished
and curtailed the scope for the court to
operate with full independence some of
the ways in which these basic principles
were eroded through law and practice let
me just hop and skip very quickly
through them because I do have an
anxious sense that I'm losing some of
you already but one of the knot guys
really fantastic is carry on with that
but one of the first of these was
announcing the president's powers to the
detriment of the chief justice under the
Fourth Amendment in 74 which imposed
one-party rule and then very critically
a fragmentation of the entire Supreme
Court by the Eighth Amendment under
Ishod and effective military rule and
then more interestingly perhaps
indirectly by the Thirteenth Amendment
which was burst by an elected
the Army League introducing the
caretaker government system which
envisaged a role for the judiciary in
the executive as well as in every level
through interference of the appointments
process the court fought back in two or
three quite critical cases the first of
these the Eighth Amendment judgment or
unrehearsed Anne's case the court
established for the first time the basic
structure doctrine and identified that a
unitary Supreme Court was part of the
basic structure of the Constitution of
Bangladesh and it was able to bring back
all of these courts all of these benches
of the High Court that had been sent off
to remote areas where they had not a
single copy of the Constitution usually
and a couple of dog-eared copies of
various law reports and no lawyers who
had ever practiced in Constitution law
but were determining suddenly
constitutional rights and obligations so
the court was restored and the other
critical judgment and here there are
very clear parallels with Pakistan and
indeed this entire case really drew its
entire sustenance and sauce from
Pakistan was the master assign judgment
a case which was brought by a member of
the subordinate judiciary asserting that
independence of the judiciary needed to
be formalized for for the subordinate
courts but the formal structure being in
place of course is insufficient the most
crucial change needed and the one quite
clearly impossible to address through
legislation alone and one unfortunately
which is - sadly manifest on a daily
basis for those of us who have to trap
the court corridors is the absence of
the cultivation of independence of mind
and spirit immune to any kind of
influence whether from partisan
political forces or other powerful
actors or agencies if the operation of
the courts continues to give rise to
fears that they are not able to operate
free of so called extraneous influences
and if there's no strong mechanism to
check partisan decision-making then
concerns regarding the accountability of
the judiciary are already very severe
will continue to multiply the
politicization of the appointment
process and the consequences of these
appointments in terms of the patterns of
judgments and orders particularly in
politically sensitive cases have led to
serious
of the image of the judiciary as an
independent institution and these issues
in turn have raised concerns regarding
the capacity the judiciary to ensure its
own accountability recent experiences of
highlighting these concerns I just share
one example to you so I think that's
kind of evocative enough without taking
you two through the whole sad history
and the multiple examples I think we
could say given the time of the ways in
which unfortunately our judiciary is
debased itself time and time again one
of these was a kind of rather
extraordinary case where you know in a
math set of appointments that had been
made by the last elected government to
the judiciary sort of desperate effort
to pack the benches before it went out
of office 19 judges were appointed to
the Supreme Court on a single day of
whom one it turned out was BAM somewhat
under suit and unqualified for office
because he was the holder of a
third-class law degree it subsequently
transpired that not only was he holding
this third-class law degree but he can
buy that through tampering with his mark
sheets so I think for many of our senior
lawyers this was just a little bit too
much to tolerate and when two of our
leading newspapers investigated these
allegations and broke the story we
thought fantastic now the Chief Justice
will rediscover his backbone in action
will be taken
some kind of backbone or some kind of
bone possibly in the head was discovered
and instead of taking action immediately
to investigate that Judge I'm sure and
says well you know what happened
contempt rules were issued against the
newspapers and we have this marvelous
law of contempt another colonial
hangover which we cling on to dearly in
our post constitutional order which
allows the judges to be judge jury and
executioner and decide that if anyone
does anything which scandalizes the
court then no matter whether there may
be a defense of truth they may
nevertheless be held culpable and
sentenced to including other things
imprisonment so in this case just as Phi
Z we took we took up the case and at one
point I remember sitting in court and
wondering what
I decided to do by choosing this
profession rather than running a
restaurant or taking up knitting or
something more relaxing because an
argument was being made that
milords you will appreciate that if the
unhappy event were to occur that one of
your Lordships were found to have
murdered to a spouse and this incident
were reported in the newspapers and an
investigation was undertaken then we
would be forced duty-bound to have that
report hidden to take action accordingly
and the judge looked out through large
open windows at the barn trees swaying
in the breeze thought for a moment and
turned back and said no dr. Hussein or
no mr. Mahmud whichever it was I don't
think that would be permissible so I
have to say that was the moment in which
we realized something was really quite
seriously wrong and we were going to
lose this case as well so subsequently
I'm happy to say that eventually as I
said the bone did return to the right
part of the body and the Supreme
Judicial Council threatened proceedings
against justice by sea and he then
thought right it's time to tender a
resignation and move on so he did that
but that in a sense is the context
within which our judiciary is operate
now our senior judiciary has been
operating now movements for ensuring
independence of judiciary and for
reconstructing the applicable legal
framework were catalyzed and driven from
within the legal system by activist
judges and lawyers with a commitment to
maintaining the integrity of the system
and enabling it to continue to deliver
justice all within existing constraints
but it's also evident that these
movements have faced continued
resistance from within the bureaucracy
and most importantly from those holding
political power at the highest levels
and elements passes on to them and loyal
to them from amongst both judges and
lawyers and that is meant we've seen how
the executive is completely unwilling to
abandon its control over the judiciary
because the power to manipulate the
political opposition through pulling the
strings of vexatious cases and also the
more general expectation of favorable
outcomes in all manner of litigation
whether politically sensitive or not is
simply impossible for them to
give up and sadly why lawyers actively
engaged in political life and members of
the bar actively engaged in movements
for democracy have advocated inside and
outside the courts for the restoration
of judicial independence they have been
far less insistent on this demand once
their favorite political parties achieve
office and indeed the consistent pattern
under all regimes from full-blown
military governments to autocratic
presidents and elected parliament swear
thumping majorities has been
consistently to reduce independence on
the one hand and further politicize the
tradition on the other and the fruits of
this political patronage exacerbated by
the carrot and stick effect and the
senior-most judges on the possibility of
their elevation to the highest office
until recently as chief advice of the
caretaker has led I think to the current
crisis that we see today the higher
judiciary still remains despite all of
this the forum of last resort against
arbitrary executive action but its
capacity and ability to provide such
protection is increasingly under
question and ironically increasingly so
under an elected dispensation and it's
clear I think that now unlike in the
past its reputation is suffered serious
erosion some of the examples again just
a couple of them very quickly before I
go on to the last and final section two
of the cases which are well known I
think from validation in recent months
very recent ones which show I think
exactly where it's moved one is the case
around the Thirteenth Amendment I said
this is the issue the Thirteenth
Amendment established that the caretaker
government which would be headed by a
former chief justice the last retiring
chief justice
now the caretaker government provision
came in in 1996 and came in in the
context of a political impasse in which
the current ruling party which was then
in in opposition refused to accept quite
rightly the results of a very heavily
rigged election a complete farce and the
solution that was brought about was this
chaotic provision inserted through the
13th amendment
subsequently of course we saw the
problem is with the Khattak expanded and
stretched beyond all realistic
possibility of survival during the two
years of decay the emergency in 2007 and
eight subsequently there I mean it
haven't been elected with the stamping
majority has decided that we'd no longer
perhaps need caretakers for transition
and now that we're in power it may be
better just to stay there and then to
see if we can hand over or not hand over
and get reelected so the third amendment
but it would be obviously a very
difficult issue to have directly dealt
with in Parliament it would seem
transparent in terms of it being an
exercise in severe democratic erosion
and the refusal to accept democratic
transition through a free and fair
election so the court was essentially
used to fire the gun and the 13th
amendment case which was the kind of
weird Public Interest case bought by
some you know lawyer who does Public
Interest cases as a matter of reflex
every few months or so suddenly it was
fast-tracked by the Chief Justice and
heard as a matter of priority over a
docket of you know tens of thousands of
cases that were not being heard eight or
nine amicus curiae I addressed the court
the Attorney General also addressed the
cause all bar one argued that in the
context of Bangladesh and given the
continuing political impasse that had
been seen between the two political
parties a limited caretaker provision
was the only way to ensure transition
despite that the Chief Justice held in a
three line order that the caretaker
provision was struck down however that
Parliament may nevertheless proceed to
retain it for the next two elections if
it's soft faith no one understood that
order it seemed very peculiar directing
Parliament and what it might or might
not - but even more important he was it
literally a two to three line order with
no reasons no full-text judgment so for
a government that prides itself in
repeatedly states that it believes in
the rule of law instead of waiting for
the full text of the judgement the
government then proceeded to develop an
extraordinary document called the
deemed amendment to the Constitution
which removed the caretaker provisions
and also put in place a whole host of
other things I shall talk about towards
the end including restoring Islam as a
state religion arguing provisions that
any criticism of the Constitution would
amount to sedition rather bizarre the
word sedition the concept of sedition
being very clearly a colonial construct
being embedded in a post independence
constitutional order the other case um
which I'll speak about very briefly
because otherwise I will speak about it
at great length because I was involved
in it is the case regarding Grameen Bank
and professor Yunus where we also saw
and I think most of you will have at
least read about this in the media that
the court behaved like I really have no
words to describe how it behaved um but
a very simple question was taken to them
of whether a government order holding
that a person should be removed from
office on the basis that the government
had recently discovered that he had
passed the age of retirement ten years
ago and had not seen fit to issue him
even a show-cause notice before passing
the order whether that could be brought
under challenge luckily and we went to
court and luckily for professor Yunus Oh
unluckily his legal team was rather more
significant than the likes of me and we
had I guess what we could say with the
top-three counsel available in
Bangladesh who was it yeah this I mean
you know this is really a pushover of
course we have to go to court and get
this settled you know first thing
tomorrow morning we went to court and
the court began to look very stressed
and in and out and back and forth
waiting for the Attorney General to
appear and after three days of hearing
refused to admit the matter refused to
ask the government to justify its
decision in any matter refused to ask
for a single document which would have
shown that for ten years the government
had dealt with Professor Yunus as
Managing Director cratan Bank and at the
highest level with prime ministers and
finance ministers and governors central
bank meeting him and the court went on
to hold that Professor Yunus
not only was the order considered not
reviewable but that Professor Yunus had
no standing to challenge his own removal
and having done that the court then went
on to give a judgment of about 26 pages
on the mayor
it's also holding that Professor Yunus
was a usurper and a trespasser in office
and the immediate consequence of that
was that the judge who gave that order
was then promptly elevated to the
Supreme Court within the next three
months and I should mention but please
nobody quote me on this that he did tell
one of our senior counsel that this was
a reason that had been exercising him
somewhat that in during the course of
the hearing about whether if he if he
was a little bit more friendly towards
our arguments that elevation might not
transpire so having talked down the
judiciary to I think the lowest possible
depths I want to end by talking it up
and discussing with you I think about
how these are the realities within which
we function but within these realities
there are real movements from the
margins and there are real contests
ations over democracy in terms of
efforts not only to expand Democratic
space but to push the boundaries of
rights discourse and rights practice
using these very courts and being fully
aware of the limits of their operations
and approach what's made this possible
first of all again as I said it's not
all despair and disillusion as I started
out with the 1990s did see a return to
the discourse of constitutionalism it
did see and we did make possible the
return to elected government made
possible the growth of independent
rights organizations and the operation
of activist lawyers who could engage in
in social activism not just in a one
point movement for restoration of
democracy demand which we had all been
embedded in throughout the period up
until the 1990s it also led that period
to judicial activism with the entry of
judges at that point at least with a
commitment to pluralism many with a
background or engagement with legal aid
or political legal work pro bono legal
work and social activism and very
importantly it the early 90s saw the
development of the notion of public
interest litigation or social action
investigation following Pakistan by a
few years in India by about a decade or
so perhaps the most critical I think of
all of the institutional developments
that we saw in the early nineties was
the growth of an engaged in Act
Media in a very independent and very
vociferous media and through all of
these process I think we also saw an
emerging political commitment from
bottom up to an understanding of
pluralism up to a point of ethnic and
linguistic pluralism but also I think
very importantly to the articulation of
more marginalized voices to the
articulation of organizations of our
devices for example of indigenous
peoples or people with disabilities more
recently and more quietly true also of
sexual minorities in the last five to
ten years of Dalits now sex workers all
kinds of organizations all kinds of
voices all kinds of people that it would
have been simply unimaginable for us to
think about as having any voice in the
political narrative prior to 1990 and
innocence these narratives I think to
link back to the grander national
narrative the history of the struggle
for liberation when we talk about that
in the grand political narrative it is
always the liberation of the nation the
liberation of the Bengali nation these
days sadly the liberation of the Bengali
Muslim nation again it's about the
language movement it's about cultural
assertions oh I think what Dena was
saying again the Bengali Muslims but the
the emergence of these voices in these
organizations allowed this to be
critiqued interrogated and transformed
in many ways so what was some of the
achievements of these changes the use of
constitutional rights the interpretation
of constitutional rights has happened
again in India and Pakistan to establish
I think new understandings so for
example the use of the right to life not
only to challenge in recent years not
very successfully I have to say after
now but to challenge extrajudicial
executions by paramilitary forces but
also very importantly and more
successfully the use of the right to
life to argue for basic economic and
social rights to use the courts and to
use constitutional rights as a shield as
I said more lever less effective and
using them as a sword I think but we are
able to use them as a shield
against for example mass displacements
or forced evictions of huge slums and
shanty towns we've been able to use also
constitutional rights and Public
Interest process processes to secure the
rights of minorities at the height of I
think the BNP jamaat coalition in the
sitive one of the depths I should say
not the height in the early 90s and when
there were massive attacks against NGOs
and secular voices and sort of anyone
really dissented from store throg voices
as well as massive development
organizations including brac and Grameen
who faced their offices being burnt down
and women involved in their
organizations facing physical attack and
so on at that time another set of
attacks also a Pakistani imports I'm
sorry to say was a very sustained set of
attacks was launched on the Ahmadiyya
community in Bangladesh and again our
court stepped up and they prevented they
they allowed a challenge to abandon
Amity publications they allowed other
interventions to protect and the
communities from violation and attack
more interestingly not more
interestingly but in a you know they
take further development rather um in in
the recent five years we've also seen
issues regarding gender equality I think
being asserted again in a more robust
fashion some of the cases that have come
up for example that people said no
please you being involved in our cases
on one which is run actually for a long
time as perhaps I should mention that
fastest and it's the well-known case
around fatwas and so-called photo ad
violence I do you need to put on record
that it's kind of a huge misnomer in the
first place this whole notion of fatwa
violence I mean as many of you will know
the issues of village tribunals
basically not even tribunals bodies of
village elders taking on issues that are
brought to them for resolution often
involving alleged breaches of community
norms sexual norms baby and so on
ending up handing out decrees of yet
saying that usually a woman has to be
subjected to some kind of quite brutal
corporal punishment but jinguk anymore
Lashley in some cases ostracism from the
community
so these father case has started being
recorded from about i mean i'm they've
been known about I guess for much longer
but they're they're sort of being paid
attention to by Jonas movement from the
early nineties onwards in fact ethos
here I think was involved in the very
first investigation of the suicide of
nutria and beggarman in more of a
bizarre slur in the northern part of
Bangladesh
now these this did this incidents
of photo of violence and the sustained
failure of the state to take any action
was challenged in the courts it started
out being challenged through a sumo to
order by a high court or an order been
given of its own volition by a high
court bench and then a very of
enthusiastic judge holding not only that
in that particular case had the relevant
state agencies failed to act to protect
this woman from violence but going on to
hold that all faith was were wholly
illegal and could not be issued
unhelpful we thought and from SK we
actually did also file an appeal asking
for some modification of that order now
that case was that that case created a
huge ruckus
there were mullahs on the streets
extremist groups on the streets
demonstrating as police firing their
lives lost and when and there was an
appeal filed not by the government but
by two persons claiming to be movies and
persons learn in Islamic law who said
that their fundamental right to issue
forth words had been curtailed by this
decision and they went to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court quite
happily took them in and accepted this
petition and for the next ten years we
just played a waiting game of trying to
make sure that I didn't know
circumstances that this case get heard
because we had a succession of
absolutely appalling benches which would
have left ahead and probably legislated
further into being if they've been given
the chance so I think we used every
possible
excuse that is known to a lawyer
including personal incapacity mylord
illness my lord senior counsel abroad my
lord feeling slightly ill my lord
feeling under the weather my lord it is
about to storm My Lord whatever we could
use and we kept it going and we kept it
alive for ten years and then finally we
had what we thought was our dream bench
which came into being I think was
earlier last year or beginning of this
year and this was the bench which was
headed by the chief justice why I missed
out actually probably the most important
judgment I should have talked about it
but it's too bad we'll do it later the
fifth amendment judgment which had
reinserted secularism in the
Constitution I missed it out because
it's now been negated by this marvelous
15 theme and meant and I feel we
shouldn't really spend any time reveling
about it any longer I also missed it out
because this chief justice had so
disgraced himself subsequently that I
can't really bring myself to talk about
his one big success so you know the
petty level in which I operate but going
back to this case so it was before what
we thought was our favorite chief
justice ever and the best possible bench
and he went ahead and again everyone was
very excited 10 amicus everyone's all
said we work from months and submissions
and so on and the court came out again
this is his new practice a two line five
line I'm sorry five line order saying
upholding actually the judgment we had
one earlier in the High Court holding
that yes all forms of corporal
punishment by bodies usurping judicial
authority are clearly unconstitutional
that I think is such a no-brainer
obviously there to uphold that part of
it and it was also hedged about with
some nice language and a bit of
international law and see during this
that it was all done elegantly and well
but in the Supreme Court they upheld
that bit and then they went on to hold
that faith was may be issued by persons
who are properly educated in religious
law on matters which relate to religious
issues now what on earth does that mean
what is a person properly educated in
religious law I think I can probably
guarantee it is never
going to be Gaia 3d and it's certainly
never going to be me and it probably
isn't going to be a disaster son or his
equivalent in Bangladesh it is more
likely to be someone who looks a bit
like Heather her son though I don't mean
that badly secondly what is properly
educated we have no explanation and most
importantly what is a religious issue
and we had this debate actually at the
very beginning in the Supreme Court
because they allowed in a whole bunch of
they had actually I guess it was a
fairly fair process that any movie wants
to come can come and make submission so
we had a line of people landing up and
the first few who hadn't quite gauged
the mood started out by saying well you
see if in a village a boy and a girl are
together something has to be done and
the only thing that can be done is
through fatwa minot and about that would
I have to say this chief justice still
had our sympathies because he glowered
and shut down this line of argument very
fast but that is the point that that can
of course be considered a religious
issue boy and girl holding hands and
doing a little bit more than that in any
village and so how are we going to now
say that issuing fatwas in those
situations and issuing decreasing they
can't do that or they have to be
ostracized for that is not possible we
don't know so this is the kind of
decision we get and I think I'm wrapping
up in my next couple of minutes there's
a whole series of other kinds of
interesting cases that have been
achieved through Public Interest what
hasn't been achieved and I think that's
what's important
I've talked I think about courts being
used to certify the gun for the
government I think we also have to be
aware about runaway courts and judicial
overreach and I'm sure we'll hear more
about this from Pakistan as well and
also about the magic wand piell's I
think this notion of judges that they
somehow when they're sitting on the
bench have got a peaked hat in a magic
wand and they can really solve every
social ills simply by issuing these five
line orders so we have orders now clean
the rivers and pollution and child labor
and domestic servitude you know whatever
you want you pretty much get it nothing
happens but we have a lot of decent
judgements we go away feeling cheerful
the media have stories to write the
judge goes home thinking
is really achieved something or she's
achieved something but really nothing
changes what we also see is on the tough
P is on the ones that aren't
softly-softly nicey-nicey you'll get
written about in international journals
and invited to conferences on things
that for example are about accommodation
with important economic interests for
example challenges to the practice of
shipbreaking
or for example illegal occupations of
flood flow zones by very powerful
agencies like the national government
Manufacturers Employees Association the
courts will not entertain those PIL or
they'll entertain it they'll do a little
bit of feel-good and then they will
throw it into the deep freeze or find
some solution where there's no
resolution and there's no real
effectiveness what we also see the other
limitations I think I talked about some
of the politically sensitive cases like
Doc's Eunice's for example what we also
seen what I think is very very
pernicious and this is really the
outcome of the politicization of the
judiciary is when when judges start
playing not the public interest but the
political interest in a big queen so and
this ties in I think with my first
discussion about the war crimes tribunal
where we see situations where were
you're trying to get protections for
individuals for example against abuse
and in police custody and you cite what
a well-established precedents of the
courts about the manner of arrest
without warrant or the manner of taking
someone into remand and so on and the
courts response and this is I've not had
this one time but many times now in the
last few years is well I don't think we
should be giving you those orders in
this case even though this case may be
about a 65 year old daughter II
Communist Party member who has been
supporting the enforcement of a minimum
wage of $40 a month for garment workers
we kind of in you cannot give you orders
in this case because if you get this
protection and you know we say that
instead of taking you and your client
into into police remand for
interrogation you're allowed to be have
them interrogated at the jail gate or in
hospital then you see the war criminals
will get that benefit and even if you
say but my lord that's not you know the
international crimes tribunal is across
the road
that's going to look into that questions
no no you see we have to all consider
the larger interest and I think that's
really the context in you know that
we're in so it is this this
contradiction of still trying to
maneuver our way through what is
actually unfortunately pretty much a
crumbling system we have to just hope
that it doesn't completely collapse
around our ears while we're all still
even though those corridors so I'm going
to end but before I end I guess I should
recall that some of you in this room
like me were here in Colombia actually
probably in another room in 1995 when
you were commemorating Bangladesh is
25th anniversary and at that point I
spoke as I started today also of about
general irshad he's kind of a bit of a
constant in my life as an example of
what clearly is impossible to achieve in
terms of justice and that there can
never be too many rewards for someone
who can be quite as wicked as while and
wily as him but at that point I had
spoken of our hopes for ensuring that
general shad who was then in custody
would be brought to trial for his crimes
not only for gross corruption but for
illegal seizure of power and for the
murder and torture of fellow citizens
but as you all know now none of that
came to pass
not only as general irshad former
dictator ensconced as a leading ally of
our very own quote-unquote daughter of
democracy but his legacy has been fully
embraced by our ruling coalition with
only a few definitely a few but barely
audible dissenting voices and that's why
I think I did start with talking about
disillusionment into disenchantment
because I think the note now that we are
not living under a coalition government
with fundamentalist forces who have you
know serious who have so-called accused
war criminals in their midst the sense
of betrayal by a party which really is
the torchbearer of the liberation
struggle is is far far worse and the
dreams that infused oppose to a
constitution of a full liberation from
colonial occupation and militarism of a
plural society of a democratic and
secular nation seem now to have been
firmly laid to rest or rather largely
empty
meaning and replaced by halle rhetoric
so the term socialism has been
reinserted in the Constitution again by
this extraordinary 15th amendment but
it's been reinserted while crony
capitalism reigns in practice and it's
the ruling order our leaders revel in
their role as the torchbearers women's
empowerment but as they go out of their
way to deny the aspirations of women
whether it's women workers in the
garment sector trying to hold on to this
measly $40 monthly wage or whether it's
women in the rural sector borrowers of
institutions like Grameen Bank who face
attack and remover from their positions
on the grounds that they are uneducated
rural women and know no better similarly
and even more strangely secularism is
reinserted in our constitution again by
the magic Amendment but alongside a
parallel provision which retains Islam
as the state religion rendered I think
somewhat meaningless by that
juxtaposition I know all the four
pillars of the original constitution of
72 secularism socialism democracy
perhaps the only one left intact and the
one we could have perhaps afforded to
move a little bit beyond or interrogate
further is nationalism in fact shrila
shares assertions of national
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and safeguarding the image of the nation
are now the knee-jerk responses of the
state to the mildest assertions of
limited autonomy by for example
indigenous peoples or Debussy's and
those who speak in solidarity with them
and these are accompanied by reframing
of the concept of national identity not
as plural multiple and diverse but
instead regressing not 40 years but I
think 60 or more perhaps the historians
can tell us to pre partition politics to
a monolithic hegemonic notion of the
bingo lean Muslim nation and as a small
code I should also mention that some of
the recent expressions by our leading
ministers are not only do we have no
indigenous peoples in Bangladesh but we
also recently I'm sure would have no
sexual minorities so don't
how many millions of years that might be
regressing the process of a duck
adopting this new and yet regressive and
repressive constitutional order as well
as its content is clearly open to
challenge and several grounds including
arbitrariness including discrimination
and yet our conundrum now really is
there's no forum for raising these
questions the courts pronouncements as
I've shown in some degree increasingly
nothing but a dim echo of executive
orders and interpretations and once the
potential check on executive excess and
as I said to be fair still capable of
serving this function in cases with
limited political cost the court is
increasingly perceived as being under
executive control whether directly in
indirectly with little scope for change
now being affected in these matters
through legal action increasingly the
only hope can be a broader political
mobilization and a challenge being
thrown by people to those who continue
to abuse power and to miss govern and
aid such processes so I want to just end
with a song as I started and I think I
guess I'm doing this because I'm
probably one of the three out of 150
million Bengalis who actually can't sing
which is a very very sad state of
affairs so I want to quote from an older
song a famous song from the freedom
movement as well called Beach art with
you be charcoal Baker who will judge the
judges it's too early for us to respond
like the singer advocates is a jonatha
today those people have awoken but I
think surely someday that time will have
to come and I can only hope it won't
take us another 40 years to get there
thank you
thank you Sarah for is this working can
you hear me
for a talk that I really want to engage
with I want I don't want anyone else to
ask any questions I just have a
discussion but Janet Lee I think I
should call on you because it's time for
me to really go so would you I mean I
have copious notes but could you spoken
for another half and I'm a little
concerned that her voice is fading so I
have a counterproposal if it would work
for all of you which is there's wine
waiting for us outside and we can
continue this conversation in a slightly
more relaxed fashion is that all right
with you Sarah because I am a little
concerned that you not leave this
conference deathly you know that you
know I wouldn't be able to get you back
here again if that were the case so if
that's all right with everybody because
of her voice we'll go outside have some
wine before you start clapping David I
need I can't thank everybody all in the
beginning so I'm sorry but I'm gonna
take a little bit of time to thank two
people before we go off and get some
wine the first is one of our benefactors
were sitting in the back there mr.
Mooney Masha Cola and we owe him a great
vote oh thanks he is hosting the dinner
for the panelists this evening it's
provided plane tickets he and his wife
Salaf have been extraordinary supporters
and I thank you very very much
and one last thanks before we go to the
wine is to my friend and colleague
downtown Deena Siddiqui Deena and I
taught a course together we discussed
many of these issues together
particularly about the feminism and
secularism panel
she came many many times up from
downtown which sometimes feels almost as
far away as another country and she came
sometimes for an hour-long meeting in
which we simply discussed what time each
panel should begin no part of this would
have been possible without her I'm very
grateful to her for having introduced me
to a whole group of scholars that we
would otherwise not have been able to
invite in particular Sarah and named and
many many others Thank You Lina for
everything that you've done for this
conference and let's go outside and have
a drink and we'll see you back all of
you all of you bright and early 9:30 yes
tomorrow morning okay